all right tyler what do you got for us
buddy
so
what i've been finding like recently
when i kind of like analyzed myself
i find that like there are sometimes
like when i go out and i'm doing things
i'll have like intuition say hey maybe
that's someone i'd like to be friends
with maybe that someone would like to
talk to but i just don't do it i'll be
like oh
i have
something that i have to attend to
that's more important or i'll always
like
not i'll find a way to get myself out of
it and i'm kind of asking what are some
things that you can like own your own
[ __ ]
well the first step in unplugging is
being aware of your own [ __ ] second
step is being aware of the [ __ ]
that's around you
so you just have to get to the first
step of unplugging which most which is
like honestly dude like it's totally
fine most guys never even get there like
90 of guys never even get there so
you even asking the question you know
being being curious about it is a good
start what do you guys think i'll tell
you
so i want to zoom in a little bit
are you just asking the general question
about how to get over your own [ __ ]
or is it more specific to this example
you're giving yeah it is more specific
it's more uh social based like i i i
would say i'm more uh
anti-social and social but once i it's
like it's it's about people that i don't
know and uh
it's opening myself up to new
possibilities of making new friends or
like it i'm pretty like uh what sort of
friends are you looking for tyler like
what do you like you know can you be
specific
i mean sometimes it's just as simple as
someone to go out with like bar bros or
something i mean it's pretty cold here
so there's not a whole lot of things to
do
uh besides like you know work out maybe
do indoor things
where do you look just uh
ohio okay
we're going to the super bowl cincinnati
all the way it's the i went to school in
athens by the way i know how cold it is
oh if you're coming out to l.a the super
bowl is going to be in l.a and it's this
whole week is going to be this city is
it's going to be insane in the city this
year that's all i can say i'm in
cincinnati and it's going to be
probably the biggest year of
30 years it's it's crazy but it's a good
opportunity for you right because
everyone's going to be out the energy is
going to be there it's going to be
festive so you know i mean part of right
that getting out of your own headspace
is sometimes just forcing yourself to go
out there
there's a great book i think it's called
uh the three second rule um i think it's
by mel robbins and so it's basically you
trick yourself into there's something
you're thinking about doing and you have
any doubt or anything about it you just
say three two one go you just count down
three to one and mentally you start
preparing yourself and you just go for
it um it's a fantastic book i highly
recommend that you read it and check it
out um that is a very very good book to
help you make that transitional step
from
thinking about things to action it's
either called the three second rule or
the five second rule but basically you
mentally do a countdown and then you
just go for it no matter what and that
will give you the good training um
in preparing your mental state to kind
of get out of your own mental block
because when you instantly start
counting down subconsciously you start
preparing yourself for action rather
than just sitting there and going like
well maybe i should maybe i shouldn't
and then 20 minutes later you haven't
done anything yeah and and i think
that's excellent right there i have a
question to go on top of that i mean so
let's step in for just a second before
that though because the the thing is
that you're doing this for a reason like
okay i always look for like what's going
on underneath and in general when you're
constantly in a situation where you're
not approaching people not making
connections you're not allowing yourself
to actually be seen by other people
you're basically hiding from the world
right you're hiding who you are from the
world
right you're not allowing anybody to see
you not allowing yourself to connect so
the question you have to ask yourself is
why do i feel like i have to hide what's
wrong with me
right or why do i not feel like i have
any value because it's that whole idea
of if they see me they're going to judge
me poorly it's a whole idea of like i
don't have something to offer
so if you look into that and figure out
why that's there
and actually show yourself why you do
have value and why there you have things
to offer
like
troy fancy uses this example a lot of
like okay if you've got a check for a
million dollars in your hand
are you going to have any fear any worry
at all going up and handing out somebody
and making their day
no right you're going to be giving
somebody something that's incredibly
valuable a million bucks no fear there's
no reason to worry about what's going on
i don't i don't buy what you just said
uh personally
uh well because it's not
feeling
feelings of inadequacy
okay there is nothing there
it's honestly
all awkwardness i hate
uh
the awkwardness of just like meeting
someone for the first time and it's just
as soon as like now why um
why does it have to be awkward how hard
is it to walk up and say hello to
somebody no it it it's always awkward i
just think that's something you have to
accept that's just how it is when you
talk to someone that you don't know at
all
never awkward for you no well you might
call yourself
is this the same guy that was like the
big lebowski
yeah that's me that's you okay yeah did
you read the book yet
yeah i read the book
how did that threesome go for you
uh did not happen so it didn't happen
okay there's a there's an episode back
way back in the day um
when you're younger yeah like i'll
i'll say this everybody's a little more
awkward when they're younger they're not
as socially calibrated but i can strike
up a conversation pretty much anywhere
anytime any place now but i'm i'm older
so i've so i've gotten past the awkward
phase and i'm an introvert too like i
don't really like to talk to crowds of
people right
but um
i mean
like like some of the
most interesting conversations that i've
had had with random strangers
um
was back when we didn't have this like
beer bug [ __ ] going on and you know
you could go to the gym and the sauna
was still open and big ass woods on you
sit in there and you're talking to like
you know there's sometimes 15 20 guys in
there and you're just in there shooting
the [ __ ] for 15 20 30 minutes right you
just have to just you know get
comfortable in any environment and trust
me like you're sitting there you know
with a towel and half the guys are not
naked anyway but i mean like even in
awkward you know scenarios you've got to
be comfortable with hey what's up man
you know or if you hear two people you
know conversing about something that
you're interested in you can kind of
like hey you know i heard you guys
talking about such and such and you jump
in on the conversation and see where it
goes but it's it's just getting used to
it you know it's the same thing with
cold approaching women it's the same
thing with intimacy it's the same thing
with
asking for a raise it's just going
through the motions you know like that's
how you develop a muscle is you pick up
heavy [ __ ] and you put it down you just
go through the motion so you just have
to push through it a skill like
everything else and the more you
exercise it the better you'll get so the
book is actually called five second rule
by mel robbins so highly recommend
checking out that book um give it a good
read or audio book um
that i think that'll be very helpful for
you
i want to go back to the question i was
going to ask you until it was
interrupted so for the first you said
for the first three seconds i think
that's excellent is is there anything
that's like
like just
you know baby steps to do that like i
don't know maybe
or just
there's plenty of exercises in there
right where it's like hey there's
somebody you know that you see standing
in line and you want to ask them a
question about an item in their shopping
cart right okay so yeah
like that right and then the book
there's a couple like little like
exercises that um you know it'll it'll
give you as examples to practice so i
said it's a very fantastic one i've
recommended it to a lot of people that
i've worked with before i've
incorporated some of that stuff myself
because i found myself in situations
where you know i pause a little bit i'm
like all right you know five four three
two one go and then yeah it's it's
amazing when something like this kind of
go and you don't think about it
yeah
and tyler
this is more for the longer run let's
say you're in your early 20s maybe when
you're 25 26
think about moving to a different city
because there's nothing wrong in having
standards there are just a lot of people
around that doesn't meet that standard
and it's okay
to move
and think about you know just figuring
out what kind of people you like first
of all and you have to know yourself
first right you're never gonna find the
love your life or your soulmate unless
you know exactly what soul you have in
here right it's the same idea about
making friends
you figure that out and then you do a
little bit of research figure out
where those people tend to congregate
and then go there
and i would encourage you to kind of get
out this week right because you can you
have a very unique opportunity with the
super bowl festivities so again like you
just you got a lot of momentum kind of
going for you so like it's gonna be the
same here in my city right in los
angeles like
every night this week is gonna be utter
and utter insanity so
again go kind of go with the fall and
put yourself out there and who knows you
might wind up with the tribe of like you
know 15 new best friends uh you know
after this week
and like one of the quick thing real
fast is like just be curious about
people
you know if you're just curious about
people there's no awkwardness because
all you're going is doing is going up
and figuring out who they are somebody
caught your eye about something great go
ask them what caught your eye it's like
hey saw you over here you had that hat
like what's up with this hat
part of the reason why joe rogan is is
such a popular podcaster is because he
has curiosity
right like he gets curious about so many
different topics and he'll just like
dive down rabbit holes with guys you
know over and over and over again
yeah and there's there's some little
tricks to piggyback on a couple of guys
points so this weekend just to clarify
some previous statements like every guy
was high class they're all
well behaved and all that stuff but some
people are in different phases their
social development so it's for so tyler
you said it you feel awkward with new
people maybe sometimes and i saw this
with other guys like little tricks that
i'd tell them like if someone catches
your eyes like i'll be obviously if it's
like an ioi especially like smile at
them just learn how to smile at someone
or extend your hand and immediately hey
i'm jared nice to meet you what's your
name or
the girl will always hold onto your hand
and then just be like oh hey i see your
you know i see you hold my hand now haha
teehee whatever and then on to the next
dumb thing but um or if someone's
looking at you from across the crowd
like wave at them or a couple guys in
the group um like hey you know come on
over but just be
be having a good time at all times even
if you're by yourself and moff and i say
this all the time on stereo like i'm
always having a good time i can stare at
a blank wall and just crack myself up
it's ripped it people think i'm crazy
but i'm not yeah so if i'm doing that
and someone walks in my field of vision
like oh hey hi i'm jaren what's up and
uh they're like oh god who's this guy
and they can feel your energy too um
especially in person
yeah so this weekend if you have the
opportunity um just get really good at
talking people make them feel good about
themselves i i know a lot of guys in our
group um even when we went out these big
social situations it doesn't always have
to be girls doesn't have to be guys your
age just anyone you talk to um bartender
doorman
uber driver just get really good at just
having conversation and having a
positive conversation with high energy
and high fun positive energy and then
that'll help you out a lot could you
explore you said making someone else
feel good about themselves could you
explore that a little bit deeper like
oh yeah that's like easy way to go i
mean right where is that conversation
101 is people like talking about
themselves yeah i mean if uh i remember
like one time i was at this place and i
walked by and this girl was just wearing
this very stunning dress and i just
walked after and i said girl i don't
know who you're trying to impress with
that dress but you're absolutely gonna
knock them dead and she completely
blushed and we had a it was and that
worked out extremely well but sam you
know
i did that a lot
like someone would catch my eye and i'm
talking like there's a point i was
already talking to some other people and
someone came in real quick and she came
up and asked me a question like oh my
just instant response because it was
genuine like oh my god you have really
beautiful eyes like
my bad you know i don't know hey i'm
jared nice to meet you but it was
completely genuine and authentic or
someone else came in and i was like wow
like you have really warm loving energy
like like you just have a good presence
to you um so not like like yeah there's
simply type comments where you're like
oh my god you're so hot like i'll do
anything for you sweetie but not that
kind of stuff but genuine comments like
hey i can tell you're a good person have
you been told that before or am i wrong
what you're going to say no i'm a
terrible human being like oh okay yeah
of course tyler tyler started to cut
across the jar but the tiger even if
you're just talking to other dudes like
i went into a really high-end bar
restaurant in nashville the first night
down there and i was waiting for the
guys and i was sitting on my own and i i
sat down there was a group of serbian
businessmen next to me and they were
having a raucous time so i just leaned
over i said guys can you keep it down
i'm trying to get drunk over here
and they they all cracked up and they
were like hey who the hell are you come
on over and join us and i just started
chatting with them so it's it's like if
you've got to approach anxiety with
girls just go talk to some dudes first
you know
it's the perfect time right you can see
some of the jersey like yeah man go team
or whatever like it's it's it's gonna be
really easy for you like uh this this
week
yeah yeah no kidding
all right thanks tyler thank you see you
buddy hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you